September 8th front cover of The Wall
Street Journal 2008 after the flood of
New Orleans and Katrina there James
Reese and Andrew O'Dwyer said this is
the best thing that ever happened to New
Orleans we're going to be able to change
it demographically geographically and
politically and if it doesn't change
we're out of here two huge businessmen
who felt as though they were going to
wield their power that way that's the
coverage that we don't hear about how
people actively use the disaster and the
misfortune of others to benefit that's
been an ongoing story when it comes to
New Orleans that we have a great
underclass that people benefit from and
and to keep that underclass is important
because that's how people make money at
the expense of others and so the other
story the greatest crime was insurance
companies not honoring any of the
insurance policies my parents paid
Allstate for 50 years and they received
$400 they said no we're we're not going
to it was a disaster a flood and so
flood insurance is the only thing that's
going to be honored and that was a
policy that's a government policy that's
capped at $150,000 so most people were
not able to come back those people a lot
of people couldn't come back because the
insurance policies that they had most of
their lives weren't honored and they
weren't be able to be made whole and and
then active this placement of people I
call displacement by delay they tore
down all public housing in New Orleans
so they could rebuild them you know
because that's the best interest of the
people but they didn't replace them one
for one they only 1/3 was public housing
and I was just in New Orleans two weeks
ago three weeks ago and they were just
framing up large portions of those
public housing developments ten years
after the fact now they know most of the
people that were there 10 years ago or
probably rooted someplace else and
that's how you displace by delay
you take 10 years to rebuild a structure
the people that within that structure
will probably live someplace else
so that's it that's the sort of
journalism and media attention that I
wish was still happening in New Orleans
because so much time and energy and
money was spent around the 10-year
commemoration to say everything is
wonderful and great and there's a
entrepreneurial spirit and we have new
people come into the city and all and
that's all true but we don't want to
look at it through rose-colored glasses
this it's a tale of two cities and we
don't want to tell just the story about
one